[Musique]
on
m
[Musique]
la république d'afrique du sud est le
pays le plus développé du continent
africain ces grandes villes n'ont pas
grand chose à envier aux grandes
métropoles modernes d'europe d'amérique
ou d'asie
le pays est un formidable moteur
économique à lui seul il produit et
exporte plus de 40% de la richesse du
continent et constituent sa zone de plus
forte expansion
pays hôte de la coupe du monde de
football 2010
destination touristique apprécié aux
paysages somptueux derrière la carte
postale se cache pourtant une nation
aujourd'hui confronté à de terribles
défis l'ancienne province du transvaal
est l'une des plus grandes régions
minières au monde le sous sol de ce haut
plateau verdoyant renferme de grandes
quantités de diamant d'or d'uranium et
surtout de platine ce minerai dont la
demande explose et qu'on utilise aussi
bien pour faire des bijoux des pots
catalytiques des engrais des écrans
d'ordinateurs ou encore des implants
médicaux les compagnies minières emplois
ici près de cent cinquante mille
salariés et continue à ouvrir de
nouveaux puits tous les angles
au coeur de cette région en plein boom
la ville de rust hambourg est à l'image
de l'afrique du sud d'aujourd'hui pleine
de contrastes et d'interrogations
[Musique]
d'un côté il y à la population aisée ce
cadre de l'industrie minière
propriétaire de ferme ou de commerce qui
vit à l'américaine dans de riches villas
sur les collines qui cernent la ville de
l'autre côté du centre ville commerçant
vibrant et coloré lorsqu'on prend la
direction des mines en périphérie de la
ville apparaissent d'interminables camp
de tôle dit provisoire qui se sont
développées depuis le début des années
80 à la faveur de l'exploitation des
sous sols kevin dowling fait partie de
cette minorité de sud africains blancs
qui n'hésite pas à se rendre presque
quotidiennement dans ces quartiers
réputés dangereux ou police et médecins
ne s'aventurent guère ce camp de
squatters ça s'appelle freedom park
il n'y a pas d'électricité pas d'eau
courante pas de ramassage des ordures ni
toilettes ni de structures de soins
aucune école rien du fait que ce soit un
camp illégal
le camp est situé entre deux foyers de
travailleurs qui approvisionne en main
d'oeuvre depuis du complexe minier mais
voilà de nombreuses personnes ont échoué
ici en particulier des femmes
vulnérables des filles et de jeunes
mères célibataires venant d'autres pays
où d'autres régions du pays et qui
cherchent à échapper à la pauvreté elle
arrive soit seul soit avec un deux ou
parfois trois enfants en bas âge et elle
tombe sur le champ dans le piège de la
pauvreté
elles sont sans papiers si elles en ont
ça ne change pas grand chose
elles ne trouvent pas de travail il n'y
a pas de travail et surtout il ya très
peu de travail pour les femmes
les femmes qui viennent de l'étranger ne
peuvent pas avoir de pièce d'identité
donc ne peuvent recevoir aucune les
allocations prévues par le gouvernment
sens de ces femmes des milliers en sont
réduites à ce que nous appelons des
relations sexuelles de subsistance c'est
la seule façon pour elle de subsister
qui est d'accepter d'avoir des relations
épisodiques avec des hommes qui ont de
l'argent
elle gagne un petit quelque chose en
échange de cette relation sexuelle et le
lendemain soir elles devront remettre ça
la plupart des mineurs sont des migrants
venant d'autres régions du pays où deux
pays voisins
laissant derrière eux femmes et enfants
au village
s'ils veulent faire venir leurs familles
se pose alors le problème de leur
logement
impossible dans les foyers de
travailleurs unisexe les mineurs qui
disposent de revenus réguliers mais en
même temps souffre de l' isolement
deviennent clients tout indiquée des
débits de boissons des alentours et de
toutes ces femmes qui n'ont
d'alternative que celle de monnayer leur
charme
le plus souvent les rapports ne sont pas
protégés des tests anonymes effectuées
sur les femmes enceintes laisse à penser
que 60% des femmes vivant à freedom park
serait séropositive
face à ce problème compagnies minières
et représentant des mineurs se renvoient
la balle
les cayes principal est celui du rejet
qui pourrait surprendre du fait que nous
nous mesurons au vih sida et en parlant
depuis 20 ans déjà les victimes du sida
sont toujours stigmatisé par leur
entourage et je suis persuadé que c'est
la raison même qui nous empêche de venir
à bout de cette pandémie
en ce qui concerne les compagnies
minières
nous souhaiterions qu'elles en fassent
un peu plus car en ce moment je peux
vous assurer que nous ne sommes pas
entièrement satisfait du rôle qui a
doublé on dirait qu'elles sont sur la
défensive et qu'elle verrait bien
quelqu'un d'autre prendre leur place
voilà en grande partie pourquoi ces
femmes sont infectées par le vih et
pourquoi elles meurent dans des
conditions terribles dans ces camps de
tôle seul sans nourriture et sans autres
aides que celle que nous leur apportons
maintenant
[Musique]
vous comprenez les malades doivent se
rendre dans un hôpital où elle doit
faire la queue toute la journée être
examinée recevoir leurs médicaments est
ensuite rentré à la maison pour les
distribution d'antirétroviraux sans un
suivi à domicile effectuées par des
infirmières qui s'occupent des malades
qui explique l'importance du traitement
inévitablement il ya le risque que les
patients ne prennent pas leur pilule à
heure régulière et ce deux fois par jour
la même voie
j'étais en tournée
outre ce système de soins à domicile qui
emploie onze infirmières l'évêque
dowling et son équipe ont mis en place
huit cliniques comme celle ci installé
dans un ancien containers ces cliniques
et leur personnel soignant plusieurs
milliers de patients toutes les semaines
et distribuer des antirétroviraux à 600
adultes et 50 enfants
[Musique]
petit
avec le soutien financier de la
compagnie minière
lévesque a également créé et apollo
euros un centre de soins palliatifs pour
les malades du sida pour lequel il a été
nommé homme de l'année 2006 par la
puissante organisation américaine de
soins palliatifs
il
là
ça
[Musique]
landa
abbas
[Musique]
il a également ouvert un orphelinat une
école primaire et mis en place des
formations pratiques pour les chômeurs
et les jeunes
[Applaudissements]
et à
cet évêque pas comme les autres est
accueilli comme un sauveur à freedom
park
lorsqu'il vient assister à la messe
dominicale elle aussi célébré dans un
double containers servant semaine deux
salles de classe ses prises de position
sur les préservatifs que n'approuvent
pas sa hiérarchie lui ont valu quantité
d'articles et de reportages en afrique
du sud comme ailleurs dans un pays où
600 personnes meurent du sida chaque
jour la question du préservatif est un
sujet plutôt délicat l'abstinence avant
le mariage et la fidélité à un
partenaire unique dans une relation
maritale monogame clairement ce sont les
seules solutions peuvent permettre au
final de stopper l'expansion de la
pandémie
c'est un changement de comportement
majeur qui doit s'opérer au pipeau mais
celui ci n'est possible que pour des
gens qui vivent dans un environnement
social économique et familiale qui leur
permettent de faire librement de tels
choix sans fardeau impossible à porter
ici les gens ne peuvent pas faire de
tels choix car ils vivent avec des
fardeaux impossible pour moi la question
est comment vais-je protéger la vie de
cette femme vulnérable
l'abstinence n'est pas une option que
mal le mariage n'est pas une option
la seule option est de lui donner
l'information selon laquelle si elle
utilise un préservatif ou si elle
persuade son partenaire dans utiliser un
elle a toutes les chances de sauver sa
vie je ne crois pas qu'en tant qu'eglise
nous ayons le droit d'exiger des gens
qui sont touchés par le sida de suivre
les enseignements officielle de l'église
dans la réponse que nous leur apportons
je crois que nous devons leur donner
toujours l'information dont nous
disposons sur le vih pour qu'ils
puissent comprendre la maladie et les
laisser faire le bon choix en fait nous
informons leur conscience pour qu'il
puisse prendre cette décision importante
qui concerne leur vie
ouais
why
[Musique]
celanese
g
à temps
da
les vertes collines du pays zoulou sont
situés au coeur de la province la plus
peuplée du pays
le kwazulu natal et ses 11 millions
d'habitants
la province la plus touchée par le sida
à la périphérie de d'urban l'hôpital
sainte-marie est l'un des plus gros
centre anti-sida du pays
il distribue des traitements
antirétroviraux à plus de 3000 patients
l'hôpital est la propriété de l'église
catholique qui est ici comme ailleurs
sur le continent
un acteur important du domaine de la
santé un acteur qui gère plusieurs
dizaines de millions d'euros et suit des
centaines de milliers de patients avec
des moyens modernes nous soyons une
population urbaine et périurbaine
d'environ 750 mille personnes l'hôpital
lui-même on a que 200 lits évidemment
nous nous occupons d'adultes et
d'enfants et toute la palette de malades
des patients environ 100000 personnes
viennent consulter où séjourne à
l'hôpital
nous avons une maternité toujours plein
qui reçoit environ 500 maires tous les
mois donc nous a coûté environ six mille
bébés par an la zone que nous couvrons
est très grande et peuple et il faudrait
l'hôpital mais il n'y en a pas d'autre
il n'y a que ça une personne sur trois
dans la rue séropositive ce que cela
signifie pour notre hôpital dans un
service comme celui ci 80% des patients
souffrent de complications liées au vih
c'est le cas de la moitié des patients
qui viennent aux consultations de
médecine générale et environ 50% des
maires de notre clinique prénatal sont
séropositives
m
boeing
la réponse apportée par le gouvernement
a été malheureusement très tardive et
encore aujourd'hui certains responsables
du gouvernement sont dans un certain
déni mais il nous continuons notre
action ce à quoi nous devons faire face
en relation au vih sida
d'abord une véritable épidémie de
tuberculose la malnutrition a réapparu
problèmes que nous pensions avoir résolu
la méningite à streptocoque ainsi qu'un
tas de maladies comme le choléra une
typhus qu'on pensait avoir maîtrisé avec
une meilleure hygiène la clinique
prénatal lorsqu'une femme était
découverte séropositive elle avait
accepté d'être testé parce qu'elle
doutait de la fidélité de son conjoint
s'il rentrait chez elle est annoncé à
son mari ou à son petit ami qu'elle
était séropositive
il la battait ou la jeter dehors et de
nombreux parents ont également jeté
leurs enfants à la rue il ne l'accepté
pas le sexe est un sujet tabou
il n'y a pas de mots dans la langue des
signes et le sexe ou l'activité sexuelle
fait on en parle qu indirectement
allusion
ouais
sainte mary dispose de plusieurs équipes
mobiles qui suivent les patients
résidant en zone rurale parfois plus de
35 km de l'hôpital le programme de cette
unité inclut aujourd'hui une visite de
contrôle auprès de dennis et de sa femme
de patients sous traitement
antirétroviraux l'église enregistre l'un
des plus forts taux de succès en terme
de traitement
ces visites sont cruciales pour
s'assurer que les patients continuent
régulièrement leur traitement
même quand il commence à aller mieux et
qu aucun problème personnel ne vienne
entraver leur établissement
[Musique]
nancy effectué ce travail de suivi
depuis plusieurs années maintenant
au fil du temps elle a appris la langue
locale le zoulou et tisser un lien
particulier avec ses patients dennis a
été le premier à venir nous voir en 2004
lorsqu'il est arrivé ils avaient un taux
de lymphocytes t de 5
c'était un homme ou nous très
traditionnel auquel aucune femme et nous
étions presque toutes des femmes à
sainte mary n'allait lui dire ce qu'il
devait faire
mille quand il devait le faire ce qui
est typique de tous les hommes hulu nous
l'avons mis sous traitement
antirétroviral avec des tas
d'explications pour lui et sa famille
car étant très traditionnel il croyait
dur comme fer à la médecine
traditionnelle
quid donc ils ont accepté de faire le
traitement
à l'époque il était gravement malade
avait aussi un coup de rêve auquel il
n'a jamais renoncé et malgré le fait
qu'ils soient si malade
le traitement a vraiment marché pour moi
car quand je suis arrivé à l'hôpital
j'étais très malade je me déplacer en
fauteuil roulant je ne pouvais rien
faire seuls tôt je n'avais pas faim
j'avais perdu tout appétit
lorsque je suis arrivé j'étais au stade
iv celui du sida maintenant je vais bien
je suis remonté au stade 2 mais je n'ai
pas encore atteint le stade 1 il a
réalisé son rêve de construire sa maison
clé de posséder un véhicule
il va bien son taux de lymphocytes t
remontent très lentement
maze il progresse et a enregistré une
amélioration nette de sa vie maintenant
il va même dire aux gens de son village
ne restent pas là rien faire allez vous
faire tester connaître votre statut
sérologique pour mieux vous faire
soigner
c'est un patient exemplaire pour tous
ceux qui sont sous traitement et mais
bon il marche vraiment tout et on voit
si la preuve c'est l'ignorance
c'est clairement un manque de
connaissance et nous avons encore tant
de passion qui viennent nous voir en
tremblant que leurs voisins apprennent
qu'ils sont séropositifs
donc il faut souvent aller parler aux
voisins et leur dire dit ces gens sont
des gens comme les autres
la seule différence c'est qu'ils sont
séropositifs en théorie toute personne
éligible pour un traitement
antirétroviral
je devrais recevoir des antirétroviraux
mais dans les faits ce n'est pas le cas
ram et se met ses pieds on estime que
près de 500 mille personnes sont
éligibles mais continuent à mourir tous
les jours parce que n'ayant pas accès
aux traitements
les raisons sont multiples parfois il
n'y a pas de programmes de distribution
dans la zone où ils vivent il y a ceux
qui ne pensent pas qu'ils sont
suffisamment malade pour nécessiter un
traitement et enfin ceux qui n'ont pas
encore accepté le fait s'ils ont le sida
j'ai éprouvé une grande tristesse à
plusieurs reprises dans ce pays en
raison du manque de volonté de
leadership politique qui existent face
au sida
c'est un problème majeur du pays si ce
n'est son problème central mais nous
n'avons pas toujours eu le niveau
d'affirmation de soutien et
d'encouragement que nous aurions
souhaité recevoir du président de la
république et des différentes personnes
qui ont une certaine influence au sein
du gouvernement élu et spip
wef klaus lors ce que les dirigeants au
sommet de l'état ne parlent pas tous de
la même voie on était alors confronté à
un grave problème les gens dans le pays
se mettent à douter et commence à penser
peut-être n'est-ce pas aussi sérieux
qu'on le dit
cette forme ce manque de clarté a été
pour moi très dommageable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
m
johannesbourg la plus grande ville
d'afrique du sud est au coeur d'une
province qui compte près de 10 millions
d'habitants dont un grand nombre y
vivent dans d'interminables touchy
soweto dobson ville les nazis heures en
quelques minutes on passe d'agréables
quartier résidentiel à d'immenses camps
de tôle comme celui de thèmes billich
les essais 25000 habitants
un groupe d'habitants du camp a décidé
de prendre son destin en main en liaison
avec la paroisse locale la vie dans les
camps de tôle est difficile c'est sept
cabanes abrite 20 personnes parmi
lesquelles seules 50 un petit boulot la
propriétaire il vit avec ses sept
enfants nés de six pères différents
vous voulez connaître notre vie et bien
voilà je bois du café noir car je n'ai
pas les moyens de me payer du laine et
du sucre libre j'ai fait creuser des
toilettes dans un trou derrière la
maison
c'est dégoûtant on respire les mauvaises
odeurs ça nous rend malades
j'ai même des boutons qui rêvent de
partout je ne travaille pas j'ai cet
enfant je n'ai pas de mari je n'ai que
mes enfants j'ai soulevé toutes les
autres cabanes pour payer de quoi manger
à mes enfants et pour les envoyer à
l'école
voilà la vie que nous vivons par ici
on appelle à les douanes les ordures ses
couverts de mouches et tous pourris il
ya même des verts qui se baladent voilà
c'est la vie qu'on vit en afrique du sud
tout ce que vous voyez là ce sont des
toilettes
il doit y en avoir huit successives on a
fait un trou là et maintenant il n'y a
plus d'endroits où creuser
on ne sait pas ce qu'on va faire quand
les dernières toiles est qu'on a creusé
seront pleines
je ne vous parle pas de l'odeur qui s'en
dégage
si ça ça nous rend malades mais que
voulez vous faire re là il n'ya pas
d'hulu trouver un travail est devenu
rare tout ça c'est l'eau sale con à
jeter après la toilette ou la lessive
l'odeur pénètrent dans la maison car les
murs des cabales son trou et vu les
conditions dans lesquelles vous vivez
est-ce que vous pensez que le président
de bkc son parti au pouvoir pourrait
faire quelque chose ils ne nous aide pas
du tout le régime d'apartheid était
beaucoup mieux et nelly b à l'époque il
y avait au moins du travail mais c'est
betting aujourd'hui vous ne pouvez rien
faire
il n'y a pas de travail pas de maison
mais c'est betty quand ils en
construisent ce sont les privilégiés
qu'ils obtiennent avoir une maison en
dur il faut avoir de l'argent quand on
n'a pas de travail comme moi autant
d'enfants et pas d'argent soir à qui ça
comment peut-on espérer en acheter ou à
louer une qui ce n'était l'été qui
quitte à être là john cottreau canada
que tout le monde
so g vous était pas ce gouvernement mais
il n'a rien fait pour moi et mon père
n'en rhône ain depuis que je met une
croix sur mon bulletin de vote ce
gouvernement et harry en fait on a mixé
et llorente teyssot gay avait qualifié
les églises que font-elles pour aider
les gens dès qu'elle les églises par
rapport au gouvernement qu elles sont
bien mieux
au moins elle s'assure qu'on ait quelque
chose à manger
elle nous donne toujours un petit
quelque chose pour ce qui la nourriture
le gouvernement dit ce sont toujours les
mêmes privilégiés qui la reçoivent
bayon les pauvres come back qui en ont
besoin si vous me demandez sur les
églises elles sont 100 % mieux que le
gouvernement
[Musique]
le groupe justice et paix de l'église
catholique de thèmes 'bullish' les
s'occupe de multiples problèmes ayant
trait à la vie locale
interdiction des décharges sauvages
amélioration de l'environnement
médiation avec la population musulmane
voisine et aide à l'obtention des
précieuses cartes d'identité
indispensables pour toucher sa retraite
ou obtenir les allocations créé pour les
enfants en situation précaire
la première pièce d'identité
là ça vaut la 12e minute entity
confirmation de l'identité
ap confirmation que votre demande a été
déposée jeans ou pouvons-nous obtenir
notre carte d'identité
c'est ça le vrai problème disons par
exemple que tu a déposé une demande pour
une carte d'identité
ta carte arrive et le lendemain tu
souhaite obtenir un extrait de naissance
pour ton enfant et c'est là où tu
apprends que tu es marié à quelqu'un
d'autre au sein donc en fait ta pièce
d'identité n'est pas une vraie pièce
d'identité
ça serait peut-être bien qu'on en
discute avec notre mère afin qu'on
vérifie toutes les cartes d'identité eh
bien peut-être beaucoup de gens qui
ignorent qu'ils ont été mariées
frauduleusement
il faudrait aussi discuté du problème de
la poste qui retient ta carte parce que
tu ne seras pas remis un petit billet
pour débloquer les choses
well lorsque tu vas à la poste il te
montre des tas de cartes d'identité now
maintenant c'est à toi de chercher dans
le tas l'une de nos chargés de mission à
soweto a dû le faire la semaine dernière
pour une carte d'identité
elle a dû chercher parmi des milliers de
cartes déposée par terre mais pour ce
que vous aider pourquoi utilisez-vous
pas l'adresse de la paroisse pour la
livraison et la carte plutôt qu'une
poste restante pas dit oui mais si la
carte est livrée à la paroisse c'est le
propriétaire de la carte qui doit être
là pour signer l'accusé de réception et
indiqué que moi
ni moque les ennemis et reçu ma carte à
telle heure tel jour parce que si tony
n'est pas là ils ne laisseront ta carte
à personne d'autre si tu vas à la
préfecture le plus souvent ils te disent
qu'ils manquent de personnel on sait
qu'ils racontent la même chanson à tout
le monde en afrique du sud
et s'il n'y a pas assez de personnel à
la préfecture pour traiter les dossiers
ça devient un vrai problème nombre de
services de l'état sont aujourd'hui miné
par l'absentéisme la désorganisation
voire la fraude et la corruption
lorsqu'ils ont besoin d'un papier
officiel les riches et les proches du
pouvoir s'en sortent toujours les
pauvres eux paient les pots cassés
d'un côté nous avons un monde développé
dans lequel les gens gagnent très bien
leur vie et de l'autre côté nous avons
des gens qui vivent avec moins de deux
dollars par jour
ces gens ont du mal à mettre sur la
table au moins un repas par jour pour
toute société dans le monde
avoir un tel niveau de déséquilibre
entre les riches et les pauvres de reach
est immoral nous affirmons notre très
grande inquiétude quant à l'absence
presque totale de sens moral dont font
preuve nos concitoyens aujourd'hui il
est important que le gouvernement
consacre du temps à et fasse preuve face
à ce défi de véritable leadership
l'afrique du sud est devenue le deuxième
pays le plus violent au monde derrière
l'irak
tous les ans 18 mille personnes sont
assassinées
trente mille armes à feu voler ou
subtilisé la population aisée vit
retranché dans des propriétés clause
derrière des clôtures électrifiées
protégé par des gardes armés
la police et soupçonnait d'inefficacité
et de corruption
pour autant le parti au pouvoir refuse
de voir la réalité en face et réfute les
statistiques de la criminalité n'est pas
si élevé que ça si on la compare à la
période précédente
la seule différence c'est qu'avec le
nouveau gouvernement
on est informé de tout ce qui se passe
dans le pays ce qui n'était pas le cas
avant d'être l'apartheid a fait de nous
une nation très brutal âge elle a rendu
notre existence violent elle a ôté toute
valeur à la vie tué et mutilé des gens
pour quelques raisons que ce soit était
devenu banal et cela a continué dans ce
pays les gens peuvent si facilement
mettre la main sur des armes
il y attend d'armes qui reste des
combats pour la libération
pas seulement ici mais aussi au
mozambique il y à des caches énorme la
criminalité touche tous les niveaux de
la société car les gens abusent de la
situation au sortir de l'apartheid
on a mis en place des lois qui veille à
respecter le plus scrupuleusement
possible les droits des citoyens
seulement on est allé si loin que les
violeurs assassins où les criminels qui
détrousse les banques et les centres
commerciaux les séjours en prison et son
relâché moyennant caution et ils
commettent les mêmes crimes à nouveau
des tic débarque chez vous et vous
disait on va vous voulez vous leur
répondez prenez tout et ne nous fait pas
de mal ils répondent très bien
nous allons prendre tout ce que nous
voulons mais nous allons aussi vous tuer
en afrique du sud toutes les 30 minutes
il y a une petite fille qui est violée
un jeune garçon qui est [__] il y à
des meurtres rituels dans les zones
rurales surtout au cours desquelles
lézignan gaz les sorciers traditionnel
tu de très jeunes enfants pour fabriquer
des potions qui sont censés pouvoir
guérir de toutes sortes de mal être
m
en afrique du sud nous assistons à des
phénomènes de beuvry pendant lesquelles
les gens qui consomment goâve au delà de
toute limite ils ne boivent pas durant
la semaine mais généralement le vendredi
et le samedi
complet il se rendait à une soirée et il
consomme jusqu'à être complètement saoul
et ne plus tenir debout et lorsqu'ils
rentrent en voiture à la maison il se
dispute avec leurs femmes
et c'est là que les problèmes commencent
un père en pleine dépression suite à de
graves problèmes sociaux menacé sa femme
avec une arme à feu avec l'intention de
la tuer la femme qui est sa fille de 3
ans dans ses bras devant elle
le père tire la balle traverse le coup
et l'enfant est paralysée du coup
jusqu'en bas pour le reste de sa vie et
vit maintenant dans un centre spécialisé
dans ce pays les jeunes dès leur plus
jeune âge adulte ce qu'ils voient comme
des stars ces gens qui font partie des
gangs qui conduisent de belles bagnoles
il les considère comme des héros
[Applaudissements]
oui nous serait très inquiet du niveau
qu'a atteint la corruption dans notre
société et nous affirmons que le
gouvernement doit faire quelque chose le
problème de la corruption et des normes
des preuves c'est nous qui faisons
partie de la société civile
lorsque nous regardons le sommet de
l'état et ses niveaux intermédiaires
nous voyons des gens qui sont arrivés à
leur poste parce qu'ils ont joué un rôle
dans la libération du pays et qu'ils
sont aujourd'hui membres du parti au
pouvoir
il clame nous nous sommes battus nous
avons souffert d'un coup nous avons le
droit de recevoir une petite récompense
en contrepartie est ainsi la frontière
entre garder une conduite honnête et l
ai pioché dans l'argent public est
extrêmement floues ces derniers temps
les qualités de leadership d'un mandela
d'un sisulu d'un oliver tambo de ces
grands héros dans l'ancienne génération
de l'insee je ne les vois pas
transparaître dans la nouvelle
génération ce sens désintéressé du
service rendu au pays
cette conscience d'être des dirigeants à
même de transformer la vie de leurs
concitoyens
ce dévouement pour le futur du pays
je ne les vois pas chez les jeunes et
titien d'aujourd'hui ce que le
gouvernement a fait a été de dire aux
églises quelle qu'elle soit oui ne vous
inquiétez pas les membres de notre parti
sont conscients de la perte de sens
moral et nous allons revoir notre
politique des droits de l'homme mais je
peux vous dire je suis au parlement
depuis 1999 et je suivais la chose avant
il n'y a aucune chance pour que changent
leur politique
cette politique est coulée dans le
marbre un stand ce pays il va falloir
bien plus qu'une prise de position des
églises pour changer tout ça
[Musique]
dans ce pays où 80% de la population se
revendique chrétienne les églises assume
un rôle social et politique vraiment
important
protestants ou catholiques elles sont
présentes partout sur le terrain des
camps de squatters aux banlieues aisées
de l'éducation à la santé
elles sont à l'écouté des besoins de la
population et traquent les
dysfonctionnements elle suscite la
réflexion sur les questions de
redistribution et de justice sociale
l'église catholique minoritaires seuls
10% des chrétiens sont catholiques est
la plus active et engagée sur le terrain
avec ses consoeurs anglicane et réformer
son implication sociale et politique est
née au moment de l'apartheid
pendant la période de l'apartheid
l'église catholique était très impliqué
dans les questions sociales et avant
tout dans la résistance à la politique
d'apartheid elle-même les églises ont dû
jouer un rôle tout particulier dans la
vie de la nation
elles ont mis à disposition des élites
noires de l'argent et des bourses elles
ont aidé les opposants emprisonnés
les familles des leaders en exil elles
ont ouvert des écoles pour que tous
puissent recevoir une éducation
la conférence des évêques catholiques
d'afrique australe qui couvrent
l'afrique du sud le botswana et le
swaziland est installée dans des locaux
spacieux au centre de pretoria
la conférence est doté d'un personnel
nombreux son bureau sida distribuer des
traitements antirétroviraux à treize
mille malades dans 29 diocèse son réseau
de santé contre 88 hôpitaux et cliniques
et des centaines de dispensaires son
bureau justice et paix a mis en place
des groupes de travail dans plus d'un
millier de paroisses les évêques
s'ils reconnaissent le travail accompli
par le parti au pouvoir la nc n'approuve
pas forcément tous les aspects de sa
politique libérale ni les déclarations
d'autosatisfaction dans un pays où 20
millions de personnes sur 50 vivent
encore dans une terrible pauvreté
nous sommes une jeune démocratie
notre démocratie n'a que 12 ans le
gouvernement formé par l'insee a déjà
réalisé de nombreuses choses il a
beaucoup fait pour le peuple et pour à
bout
les gens ont accès à l'eau haute accès à
l'électricité est bouclé l'accès à
l'éducation pour tous mpt a reflué
aujourd'hui les gens sont libres et que
nous comme ils peuvent s'installer où
ils veulent aussi longtemps qu'ils
peuvent subvenir à leurs besoins et nous
avons créé des allocations pour les
enfants les personnes âgées et les
handicapés pour les aider tout comme
tubes comme si ce n'était pas comme ça
avant les politiciens font de la
politique
l'idée shop les leaders de la communauté
religieuse n'en font pas la libération
politique qui ne veut rien dire pour moi
tant que les gens et en particulier ceux
qui ont été oppressés et ont souffert
nous pas été sortis de la misère et la
pauvreté afin de se voir offrir une
existence digne
je pense qu'il est plus difficile de se
battre pour la justice sociale que pour
la justice politique
nous avons combattu l'apartheid c'était
notre ennemi mais maintenant pour gagner
cette justice sociale nous devons
disposer des dernières études et
statistiques
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
créé un bureau auprès du parlement
un bureau justice et
est ce un bureau échanges commerciaux il
est nécessaire d'avoir les spécialistes
si en tant qu'eglise nous voulons être
capables de prendre à bras le corps les
vrais problèmes qui diminue la qualité
de vie de nos concitoyens
[Musique]
les églises n'hésitent plus à s'immiscer
dans la vie politique et parlementaire
là encore ce sont les catholiques qui
sont les plus présents leur bureau de
liaison auprès du parlement
installé dans la ville du cap emploie
une dizaine de personnes
sous la responsabilité du père peter
john pierson le bureau interpelle les
parlementaires sur les grands problèmes
de société
les conseils lors des discussions
budgétaires et les assiste dans la
rédaction des lois
il collabore avec des chercheurs et des
universitaires comme ici l'institut de
l'enfance de l'université du cap qui
militent étroitement avec l'église en
faveur de la protection des enfants
80% de l'aide de la prévention et de la
protection de l'enfance est assuré par
la société civile et les églises sont
des acteurs majeurs dans ce domaine
les églises sont présentes dans de très
nombreuses villes et villages ou dans
des zones où vous ne trouvez pas de
médecin d'assistante sociale je poste de
police 4 les églises apporte un réel
plus en terme d' aide et d'assistance
dans les zones rurales dans les camps de
squatters où il y à une carences
criantes
nous sommes impliqués dans un grand
nombre de sujets qui touchent aux
problèmes des pauvres et des exclus
s'il ya une chose que les parlementaires
après si c'est notre engagement et notre
force de conviction l'église un rôle
énorme à jouer nos préceptes catholique
en matière sociale sont en quelque sorte
notre botte secrète car je ne pense pas
que nous ayons en tant qu'eglise fait
assez pour les mettre en avant dans
notre monde
la solidarité le bien commun la primauté
des pauvres l'option des pauvres il faut
les traduire dans des programmes qui
vont changer la mentalité de communautés
entières de plus en plus le gouvernement
a admis le fait qu'il devrait travailler
plus étroitement avec les églises
qu'elle représente le bon rôle est celui
qui a véritablement les moyens de
toucher les gens sur le terrain
[Musique]
comme si les problèmes de pauvreté de
sida et de criminalité n'était pas déjà
suffisant l'afrique du sud doit faire
face depuis plus d'une dizaine d'années
un afflux de réfugiés politiques
économiques venant des quatre coins du
continent
combien sont ils aujourd'hui en afrique
du sud personne ne le sait vraiment 6
millions 8 millions 10 millions
leurs histoires sont bouleversantes et
leurs conditions de vie déplorables
dépasse souvent l'imaginable
[Musique]
mme dalloz del mon père faisait de la
politique c'était durant la période du
président mouiller la situation était
très tendue
so hilda pour se débarrasser de lui
ils ont mis du poison dans sa boisson et
il est mort ma mère incapable de gérer
la situation et s'est retrouvé confronté
à de nombreux problèmes
si bien que ses plus grands enfants
comme moi ont dû quitter le foyer et
s'assumer j'entendais mes amis me dire
que la vie est plus facile en afrique du
sud par rapport au reste de l'afrique à
dakar
donc j'ai décidé de venir ici donc je
suis parti de kisumu pour nairobi à
nairobi j'ai pris un autre bus pour dar
es salaam dar es salaam j'ai pris un bus
pour la zambie plomelin temps mis pour
le zimbabwe et du zimbabwe je suis passé
en afrique du sud
what we mais nous avons dû traverser la
frontière à pied
j'ai accouché d'un garçon en tanzanie et
je me suis aussi lille avec un homme là
bas qui est maintenant le père de mes
deux autres enfants adaptant kid
jusqu'à présent il n'a pas vraiment
trouvé de travail si vos mini moi
d'ailleurs au kenya j'avais quelques
connaissances de secrétariat
mais depuis mon arrivée je n'ai pas été
capable de faire croire ce soir le nid
de trouver du travail
c'est très difficile les diplômes des
autres pays ne sont pas vraiment
reconnue et du match faut donc pour une
étrangère le mieux qu'on peut espérer
c'est de vendre des choses dans la rue
et nous mais bien avec bing cole porter
des fruits mais des biscuits 8 like
dette au may be go to hell ou de
travailler dans un magasin et j'ai riant
et donner un coup de main pour vendre
des habits lowe's et tu attends et
appelle les clients mais n'a que c'est
sûr que je ne m'attendais pas ça en
venant en afrique du sud les sud
africains honnêtement et comme les vrais
sud africain du pays des anneaux mais ne
sont pas très accueillant ils
n'accueillent pas très bien les
étrangers et les mavs
comment je vais trouver du travail et
offrir une vie stable à mes enfants afin
qu'ils puissent recevoir ce dont ils ont
besoin et que leur avenir ne soit pas
hypothéquée
au fond ce qui concerne l'afrique du sud
amstel je ne suis pas encore sûr de
savoir si c'est le bon bout et a aidé
mais je ne sais pas si je vais arriver à
trouver un travail
we made aujourd'hui ma mère est veuve
j'ai encore deux jeunes frères et soeurs
et je sais qu'elle a déjà toutes les
peines du monde pour les nourrir
et les envoyer à l'école même to take
them to school droit la pire des choses
que je puisse lui faire et de débarquer
avec trois enfants qu'elle ne veut pas
me chasser elle ne me chassera pas mais
pense aux soucis que ça créerait pour
elle ça risquerait de vraiment lâché
c'est la raison pour laquelle il est
préférable que j'essaie de survivre de
mon côté et qu'elle ne me vois pas
[Musique]
et il
moi
meyer
il
il y a
[Musique]
higuain
il y a
[Musique]
il
le foyer bienvenus géré par des soeurs
de l'ordre scalabrini a été créée pour
accueillir et loger des femmes réfugiées
leurs enfants et les aider à s'intégrer
dans la société sud africaine
c'est ici que perez et ses trois enfants
ont trouvé accueille le foyer aide les
femmes à obtenir des papiers provisoires
faire leur demande d'asile à scolariser
leurs enfants ou encore se soigner
[Musique]
il
différentes formations sont offertes
comme des cours d'anglais ou ses cours
d'informatique dispensés par un étudiant
camerounais en général au foyer on
accueille les femmes jusqu'à ce qu'elle
puisse retomber sur leurs pieds
nous avons donc en principe de limiter
leur séjour à six mois pendant cette
période
elles vont tenter de se faire une petite
place nous les encourageons à essayer de
s'intégrer dans la société
on ne peut pas rester dans une situation
de dépendance indéfiniment la
communication est vraiment difficile
souvent elles ne sont pas comprises il
ya de la xénophobie
les gens ne comprennent pas deviennent
ces femmes de quel environnement
car dans la plupart des cas elles ont
été forcées de quitter leur pays sous
peine d'être tués
comme elles doivent obtenir des papiers
de réfugiés nous les en général cela se
traduit par des longues attentes devant
la préfecture
parfois pendant plusieurs jours les
enfants s'adaptent plus facilement
qu'ils savent c'est une bénédiction à
petit au début en général les enfants
sont timides et réservés
mais après quelques temps une fois
qu'ils ont fait connaissance avec les
autres enfants et commencer un lien
l'école ils deviennent plus communicatif
s'ils ont été traumatisés on les aide
avec une psychologue mais généralement
ils s'adaptent assez vite
tu sais si nous nous employons à faire
que ces gens se sentaient bienvenus ils
vont s'intégrer et ils ont beaucoup à
offrir
ils peuvent beaucoup apporter à ce pays
et en fonction de ce que le futur leurs
réserves
ensuite il pourrait très bien devenir
partie intégrante de ce pays arc-en-ciel
que l'on appelle l'afrique du sud
[Musique]
je me tiens à la fenêtre de mon bureau
et je regarde les enfants qui sortent de
l'école en école qui n'est plus séparé
du pointu raciale je regarde ces enfants
qui se conduisent comme des enfants et
et échangent leur amitié qui partagent
leur humanité et ce que je vois là sont
les acteurs en herbe de notre société
future qui se doit d'être meilleur
[Musique]
m
fait il
[Musique]
devant l'afflux de centaines de milliers
de supporters pour la coupe du monde de
football et celui des 2 millions de
touristes qui visitent le pays tous les
ans l'afrique du sud devra si elle veut
se montrer sous son meilleur jour penser
rapidement ses plaies maîtriser sa
criminalité sa pauvreté et son sida
comment la nc et ses représentants vont
ils y arriver et les églises réussiront
elles à amener le gouvernement et les
classes aisées encore plus de solidarité
de partage pour que la nation
arc-en-ciel puisse véritablement
justifier son appellation